Peter the fallout from Snowden continues
hard to believe Betty that it's been a
year since he became as you said a
household name went public with his
story but a lot has happened in that
interim period Edward Snowden has
sparked an international debate over the
balance between national security and
civil liberties he's put the United
States on the defensive in that debate
he's also triggered changes here in
Washington proposals from the Obama
administration and from Congress to
change how the NSA does business that's
a work in progress right now and there's
been a business impact as well Betty as
you know tech companies say they've been
tainted by all the debate over American
surveillance programs it's hurt their
business overseas as they've been seen
as conduits for the federal government
that's created a much more adversarial
relationship between us tech companies
some of the biggest in this country and
the federal government that's a tension
that would not be there if it hadn't
been for Edward Snowden stepping forward
a year ago and Peter there are certainly
that's the case but there are also
proposals to change the surveillance
programs but just proposals right now
right no action
that's right there really hasn't been
that much concrete change so far as a
result of Edward Snowden but that could
be changing even the next few weeks you
had the president stepping forward in
January outlining some changes that he'd
like to see with the surveillance
programs the big idea there being vetti
the end to bulk collection no longer
would the government collect all those
phone records out there instead he wants
the private sector the phone companies
to hold on to those phone records and
let let the government search them under
court order after the after the fact if
you will that's where Congress is
heading right now there's a bill that's
passed the House of Representatives but
there's some problems already surfacing
in the Senate with this is the same idea
and one of the problems is the phone
companies don't want the responsibility
they don't want have to hold these
records themselves for the government
and the other thing is Betty they don't
all save the same thing not all this
information may be in the format that's
that's readily usable by it by the
government so that's one issue and then
there's the civil liberties issues as
well they're real problems with with
language in the House bill civil
liberties groups and some of the tech
companies say it's still too broad
there's still a backdoor to bulk
collection they don't think it's good
enough and that's where the tension is
right now up on Capitol Hill and between
the tech companies the civil liberties
groups well you mentioned the tech
companies
what about the business impact on them
well they say it's real I mean they
point to Brazil getting rid of Microsoft
Outlook for example within government
offices China looking at the use of IBM
servers at Chinese banks these the tech
company say real impact on their bottom
line and there's been some estimates out
there by 2016 there's one estimate that
it could cost the cloud computing
business 35 billion dollars others say
it could be as much as a hundred and
eighty billion dollars Betty we're
talking about real money here and you
can see why it is they're so concerned
about the federal government right now
in that relationship going forward oh
you can imagine